welcome everyone this is part five in
our series on natural language inference
we're going to be talking about
attention mechanisms attention was an
important source of innovation in the
nli literature and of course it's only
grown in prominence since then
let's begin with some guiding ideas in
the context of the nli problem we might
have an intuition that we just need more
connections for a lot of our
architectures between the premise and
hypothesis right possibly in processing
the hypothesis we just need the model to
have some reminders about what the
premise actually contained and whatever
summary representation we have of that
premise might just not be enough from
the point of view of processing the
hypothesis and feeding the
representation into the classifier layer
relatedly you know there's a persistent
intuition in the nli literature that
it's useful to softly align the premise
and hypothesis to find corresponding
words and phrases between those two
texts it can be difficult to do that at
a mechanical level but attention
mechanisms might allow us via our
data-driven learning process to find
soft connections in the weights for
these attention layers between the
premise and hypothesis and achieve some
of the effects that we would get from a
real alignment process
so let's begin with global attention
this is the simplest attention mechanism
that you see in the noi literature but
it's already quite powerful and as
you'll see it has deep connections with
the attention mechanisms in the
transformer
so to make this concrete let's start
with a simple example we have every dog
danced as our premise some poodle danced
as our hypothesis and they're fit
together into this chained rnn model for
nli
now standardly what we would do is take
this final representation hc
as the summary representation for the
entire sequence and feed that directly
into the classifier
what we're going to do when we add
attention mechanisms is instead offer
some connections back from this state
into the premise states the way that
process gets started is via a series of
dot products so we're going to take our
target vector hc
and take its dot product with each one
of the hidden representations
corresponding to tokens in the premise
and that gives us this vector of
unnormalized scores just the dot
products
and it's common then to soft max
normalize those scores into our
attention weights alpha
what we do with alpha is then create our
context vector and the way that happens
is that we're going to get a weighted
view of all those premise states each
one h1 h2 and h3 is weighted by its
corresponding attention weight which is
capturing its kind of unnormalized
notion of similarity with our target
vector hc
and then to get a fixed dimensional
version of that we take the mean or it
could be the sum of all of those
weighted views of the premise
next we get our attention combination
layer and there are various ways to do
this one simple one would be to simply
concatenate our context vector with our
original context uh target vector hc and
feed those through a kind of dense layer
of learned parameters
another perspective kind of similar is
to give the context vector and our
target vector hc each one their own
weights and have an additive combination
of those two and again feed it through
some kind of non-linearity
and you could think of various other
designs for this and that gives us this
attention combination h tilde
and then finally the classifier layer is
a simple dense layer just as before
except instead of using just hc we now
use this h tilde representation which
incorporates both hc
and that kind of weighted mixture of
premise states
it might be useful to go through this
with some specific numerical values here
so what i've done is just imagine that
we have two dimensional representations
for all of these vectors and you can see
what i've done here is kind of ensure
that proportionally every is a lot like
this final representation here
and then that kind of similarity drops
off as we move through the premise
states and you'll see what happens when
we take the dot products here so the
first step gives us the unnormalized
scores and you can see that the highest
unnormalized similarity is with the
first token followed by the second and
then the third
the softmax normalization step kind of
just flattens out those dot products a
little bit but we get the same
proportional ranking with respect to hc
here's that context vector and you can
see it's just a mean of the weighted
values of all of these vectors that
gives us k
and that k is then fed into this
attention combination layer and you can
see in orange here this is the context
vector two dimensions down here we have
hc just faithfully repeated and then
this matrix of weights wk is going to
give us in the end after this
non-linearity
h tilde
and then the classifier is as before
so that's a simple worked example of how
these attention mechanisms work and the
idea is that we are kind of
fundamentally
weighting this target representation hc
by its similarity with
the previous premise states but all of
them are mixed in and the influence is
kind of proportional to that
unnormalized similarity
there are other scoring functions that
you could use of course we've just done
simple dot product up here but you can
also imagine having learned parameters
in there
or doing concatenation of the learn
parameters this is a kind of bilinear
form and this is just a concatenation of
those two states fed through these third
weights and once you see this kind of
design space you can imagine very a lot
of other ways in which you could mix in
parameters and have different views of
this global attention mechanism
we could go one step further here that
was global attention in word by word
attention we're going to have a lot more
learned parameters and a lot more
connections between the hypothesis back
into the premise
so to make this kind of tractable i
picked one pretty simple view of how
this could work and the way we should
track these computations is focus on
this vector b here because we're going
to move through time but let's imagine
that we've already processed the a state
and we will subsequently process the c
state so we're focused on b
and the way we establish these
connections is by taking the previous
context vector that we created that's ka
here
we're going to multiply that by repeated
copies of the b state and that's simply
so that we get the same dimensionality
as we have in the premise over here
where i've simply copied over into a
matrix all three of those states
and we have a matrix of learn parameters
here and an additive combination of the
two followed by a non-linearity that's
going to give us this m here which kind
of corresponds to the attention weights
in the previous global attention
mechanisms
we're going to soft max normalize those
and that literally gives us the weights
and you can see that there's some
additional parameters in here to create
the right dimensionalities
and then finally we have the context at
b so that's going to be a repeated view
of all these premises weighted by our
context vector as before and then fed
through some additional parameters wa
here
and that gives us as you can see here
the context representation for the state
b
when we move to state c of course that
will be used in the place of a here and
c will go in for all these purple values
and the computation will proceed as
before and in that way because we have
all of these additional learn parameters
we can meaningfully move through the
entire sequence
updating our parameters and learning
connections from each hypothesis token
back into the premise so it's much more
powerful than the previous view where we
had relatively few learned parameters in
our attention mechanisms and therefore
we can only really meaningfully connect
that from the state that we're going to
feed into the classifier so this is much
more expressive
right and then once we've done the
entire sequence processing finally we
get the representation for c here as fed
through these mechanisms and that
becomes the input to the classifier that
we ultimately use
the connection with the transformer
should be apparent this is going to
return us back to the global attention
mechanism recall that for the
transformer we have these sequences of
tokens with their positional encodings
that gives us an embedding here and at
that point we establish a lot of dot
product connections and i showed you in
the lecture on the transformer that the
mechanisms here are identical to the
mechanisms that we used for dot product
attention it's just that in the context
of the transformer we do it from every
state to every other state
and then of course the computations
proceed through subsequent um steps in
the transformer layer and on through
multiple transformer layers potentially
and there are some other variants right
this is just the beginning of a very
large design space for attention
mechanisms let me just mention a few we
could have local attention this was
actually an early contribution in the
context of machine translation and this
would build connection between selected
points in the premise and hypothesis
based on some possibly a priori notion
we have of which things are likely to be
important for our problem
word by word attention as i've said can
be set up in many ways with many more
learned parameters and the classic paper
is the one that i'm recommending for
reading for this unit reptessio at all
where they do a really pioneering view
of this
and using even more complex attention
mechanisms than i presented under word
by word attention but following a lot of
the same intuitions i would say
the attention representation at a time t
could be appended to the hidden
representation at time t plus one this
would give us another way of moving
sequentially through the sequence having
meaningful attention at each one of
those points as opposed to the global
attention which would just be for that
final state
and then there are other connections
even further afield like for example
memory networks can be used to address
similar issues and they have similar
into intuitions behind them as attention
mechanisms as applied to the nli problem
and that's kind of more explicitly
drawing on this idea that we might in
late states in processing need a bit of
a reminder about what was in the
previous context that we processed